hey guys my name is Manny Jacinto from
the good place and I will be reading
your thirst tweets mainly Jacinto if
you're reading this you are cordially
invited to crush my head between your
arms here at my house in Verdun Quebec
merci beaucoup Podesta mayor Salem
flattering in French the fact that
marriages cinco can act and dance is
also so damn gorgeous is a travesty like
if I find out he can sing too I'm
throwing this whole bussy at him with
winsome [ __ ] got it can I sing maybe in
the shower let's yeah I can work on it
so that we can yeah maybe make that
happen somehow manage acento spit in my
mouth challenge
eret I would honestly let Manny just
until light birthday candles in my ash
whole not not the other one watch the
good place y'all he said it not me
watch the good place you know you also
said the other thing but ignore that I
want manager cinto to split me open
sternum into belly button using his jaw
sternum to me right here there that's it
thank you
if you're not attracted to many jacinto
have you seen a picture of manager said
oh damn it
I'm not good with compliments especially
about stuff manager sinto could slit my
throat oh man a lot of violent things
going on with that jawline of his and I
swear the gurgling noises you hear as a
blood poured out my jugular would be a
sound of P Robles man people are pretty
damn creative just accidentally ran into
the entire cache with a good place in a
hotel lobby
Manny just sent those arms it should be
protected like the national parks oh man
I yeah that'd be great
I'd like to thank Manny just sent over
inventing bone structure I did not but
it would be great if I did hi my manager
Cynthia destroyed my uterus TBH dot dot
dot Manny just sent those Adam's apple
that's the tweet I have yeah it's
protruding the good place is manager
Santos bone structure you can thank my
parents for that why does everyone hate
me
also Manny Jacinto is hot everyone
doesn't hate you I love you and thank
you I wonder if instead of this already
late paper my professor would accept the
collage photos oh the manager sent those
arms I mean thank you because really
they're just for show made you think
those jawline and cheekbones could cut
glass
he's got features like they were
designing a lab to be specifically
perfect replying to Darcy card and Darcy
initiated this comment I love her very
much
oh my gosh lo and behold the last one
from mr. Lin Manuel
manny Jacinto is so handsome that when
his pic popped up in this link I
murmured that can't be right
out loud I don't know what to say man
when you are too kind stop instigating
all these other people you have other
things to do more important things to do
you're saving the world with your
writing but thank you for this tweet so
Thank You Lin thank you guys I'm gonna
go outside and fan myself from all this
sweat the intention is what counts so
you guys belong in a good place
[Music]